better late than never Democrats quickly
catching on to the fact that this Joe
Biden guy has bungled the Border NYC
mayor Eric Adams calling on the
president to declare a state of
emergency as his City runs out of room
to house migrants in Massachusetts
Democrat Governor is outright declaring
one over her State surge
the immigration system in this nation
is broken New York City has been left to
pick up the pieces New Yorkers could be
left for 12 billion dollar bill this is
a national issue that Demands a national
response today I am declaring a state of
emergency in Massachusetts and
critically
I am delivering an urgent and formal
appeal to the federal government for
intervention and action and you know Joe
Biden is screwed when the liberal media
and the squad are calling out his border
failures
we need leadership from President Biden
period Democrats are looking bad right
now in New York state and that's
unacceptable when we have to win at
least four congressional seats to take
back the house so hopefully the
president is listening you you look at
these scenes out of New York you look at
the scenes out of out of Massachusetts
it's a state of emergency there's
nothing positive about this uh for for
anybody involved here and this is just a
situation that looks to be completely
out of control
we've got some show on a local channel
in New Jersey yeah it's called Happy
Days with Joe very strange couple
um this is again I got to point out the
process of matching liberal consequences
to Liberal fantasies this has achieved
probably more than anything Republicans
have ever done bussing migrants now it's
put they have to face their own problems
it's brilliant it's harrowing and it's
an emergency but this is the only way it
could have been solved so one of the big
motivators for the border state Governor
to decide to start busting migrants was
because the White House would condemned
anyone on the border for taking action
any state government for taking action
at the border and the White House would
say well this is a federal government
responsibility well no kidding and
nobody would cared that show that local
show Happy Joe they didn't care about
anybody in the border states yeah no but
so then they start busting the migraines
and that was racist and bigoted right
now you have these Governor mayors of
major cities having to say we need a
state of emergency but what are they
doing the Dewey said that's going to
backfire one they might get Biden's
attention but they're also asking for
more resources and immediate access for
migrants to get jobs do you think that
disincentivizes any migrants from coming
across no because then you're going to
have more money and opportunities for
jobs sooner that's not going to stop the
flow so that is a big problem I do say
that those governors were the for
example let's just talk about Governor
Abbott he was called every name in the
book but he stuck with it and now you
actually have Governor Healey saying
this is a national problem for once we
all agree yeah you know judge it kind of
it is frustrating when you hear these
leaders saying it's a national problem
because they spent so many years
preening Behind The Virtue signal of
sanctuary cities while mocking all the
border state leaders yeah so now they're
now they're like oh my God it's an
actual problem it's like well you could
have watched the five
and figured this out a lot three years
ago that's right well it's you know it's
like what I said yesterday you know they
condemn the movement of the of the
migrants from the southern states they
called it a political stunt they said it
was inhumane they said it was racist and
what they did was they then came out to
welcome them and they said like mayor
Adams we're a sanctuary City let's meet
you at the bus and I'll shake your hand
and we'll get you into all the hotels in
fact 50 percent of the hotels are filled
with migrants and then all of a sudden
when there's just too many they say gee
you know maybe we got it wrong but if
you listen to Jamal Brown It's not that
it's we got it wrong because the law
says they can't come in it's because
we're Democrats and we're going to look
bad and they're going to look and
they're going to lose and they know that
but it's yet another example of how the
Democrats want to reinvent the wheel
they want to cancel everything that that
Donald Trump did they didn't want remain
in Mexico they didn't want to build the
wall they didn't want to do anything and
then they have the consequences now
we've got school starting in a couple
weeks do you know how many local schools
have got the higher teachers who speak
10 different languages that they don't
even know in order to get started no
one's even talking about that I mean it
is it's a nightmare you know I thought
Harold I thought your idea in the break
was absolutely brilliant when you said
all of these new workers why not have
them build the wall and I thought that
was just amazing you solved two problems
they get jobs they build the wall you
should be our borders are I don't even
remember half the things that I say
Obviously in the green room look Biden
has been on the defensive on immigration
in the Border since since he took office
if I were him and if I were advising him
this is the time for him to build a
bipartisan group of border state
senators in congress and bring them to
the White House do what president Trump
and other presidents have done sit them
around the table let the press in and
say let's hammer out something here on
four or five things we can agree on
we'll build a wall let's do it two let's
increase border patrol and let's
increase agents three let's stop busting
people around the country because this
is not working it was a bit of a gimmick
at the beginning but I agree with
everyone around the table we're now
seeing the kind of pressure that it puts
on Albert it doesn't matter if you're
democrat or republican as a mayor
Governor these are real issues these are
real people and these these issues cost
real money and create create great
pressure why stop why stop it if it's
working but it's not no no it's working
please so the stunt which you can't
criticize Congress and Bowman you
mentioned you said Congressman you meant
Bowman I want them to criticize you for
that he said he wanted to do it for the
politics we can't just do it for the
politics we need to fix it three let's
develop a real strategy to invest in the
in the hemisphere vice president Harris
this is a responsibility it's been
assigned to you I think it's it's never
too late to step up and and provide this
kind of leadership uh three we had to
develop a strategy to go up to the
cartels both President Biden and
president Trump president president
Trump had some creative ideas about how
to go up their cartels we should think
more creatively and out of the box about
how we do this and finally we should it
should not be lost on anyone we need not
only a new immigration policy to help
protect our border but we do have a
worker shortage challenge in the country
I'm not saying let everybody in I'm
saying let a select group of people in
right but it won't happen unless there's
leadership at the top
um I know it's a little boring but uh
that's the kind of stuff I I tuned
[Laughter]
Jesse I think there should be a new
measurement of time called the Fiverr
and that is the amount of time between
us pointing out a serious serious
problem and everybody else in the media
from Happy Joe of suddenly coming to the
same conclusion three years later I call
that a Fiverr I call that a five or two
yeah let's go with that
this Adams guy yeah it's pathetic he's
tiptoeing around calling Joe Biden out
he's already gotten kicked off of the
re-election committee go for it right
say Joe Biden you yeah I'm talking to
you get down here and help us out get
control of the Border give us the money
and figure it out this is killing us
here why doesn't he do that why is he so
scared of Joe Biden it's nothing to be
afraid of Bowman's not scared of him
Bowman name checked them good for Bowman
I don't care if he does it for political
reasons as long as he does something get
Joe Biden's attention Scarborough Joe
Biden watches that show every morning
it's the only thing he watches on TV so
Scarborough knows he's talking to the
president and he's trying to warn the
president this is a political problem
and they just basically admitted that
the Democrats aren't going to do
anything about a problem until it
becomes a political problem so the
Republicans have to take the problems
the Democrats are making and make them a
political problem for the Democrats
Republicans aren't smart enough to
figure out I mean I finally Abbott and
and DeSantis figured it out but if the
National Party can figure it out how to
make fentanyl a political problem for
the Democrats how to make crime a
political problem how to make inflation
a political problem that you got to put
the heat on the Democrats because
they're all politics they don't care
about the people they care about their
own power yeah hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else